hey gq i'm emmanuel lacho and i'm going
undercover on the internet
this is actually me first up
wikipedia on january 9th
2015 eagles fan hannah delmonte
contacted acho via instagram
delmonte asked otto to escort her to her
junior prom if he received 2 000
retweets on twitter
acho felt 2 000 retweets was too low
because it was
so he increased it to 10 000 retweets
and gave delmonte
one week to meet the goal less than
three hours later del monte posted a
picture showing that she'd received over
10 000 retweets
and acho accepted the invitation junior
prom was as awkward as it can be for a
26 year old man
um i think i was 26 i might have been
24. but get this i didn't have a prom at
my high school because i went to an
all-boys school growing up st
mark's school in dallas texas we wore
uniform white shirts
gray slacks every day i'm still scarred
by that experience
so junior proms the 24 year old nfl
linebacker was in fact
my first and only prom experience the
tricky part is
what do you talk about with 16 and 17
year old
kids so i'm sitting there like so
um how's a pre-cow uh algebra is still
fun sine cosine tangent is that what
y'all were talking about these days
it was fun it was cool i played the
piano at junior prom
and i was still surprised that she got
all those retweets but hannah delmonte
and i
are still friends to this day let's move
on to cora
first question does white privilege
really exist in the usa
as of 2020 the answer to that question
is very simply yes
but hear me when i say this there are
all different types of privilege
white privilege is simply defining this
privilege that we're prefacing and
talking about
as a white privilege white privilege
doesn't mean your life hasn't been hard
white privilege simply means your skin
color it hasn't contributed to the
difficulty in your life
you can have different types of
privilege you can have ceo privilege you
can have famous person privilege
i was uh walking to a restaurant the
other day in california
and somebody was like hey emmanuel i
love what you do your meal's on me
that's famous person privilege you can
have hood privilege
the only problem is hood privilege
really doesn't help you outside the hood
so does white privilege exist in 2020
it in fact does not to say other
privileges don't exist but white
privilege
it most definitely exists submit moving
on to
twitter
why does it have to be uncomfortable
uh the conversations uncomfortable
conversations with the black man
technically it doesn't have to be
uncomfortable i try to make these
conversations as comfortably
uncomfortable as they can be
i think it has to be uncomfortable
though if you will
because people don't like to talk about
race you know growing up we talk about
uh religion we talk about sex we talk
about
so many other things money and finances
but we don't
talk about race and it's either because
we're not
exposed to people who don't look like us
often enough
or we're just scared or timid to say the
right thing as opposed to saying the
wrong thing
incidentally so the conversations don't
necessarily have to be
uncomfortable and i personally try to
keep them from being uncomfortable
but uncomfortable conversations with a
black man just has a good ring to it if
i'm being honest
posted next question not to deviate too
far from your point
but what and who defines success
is it strictly monetary do others define
one's success that's a really good
question i think society has defined
success
for us and i think success is defined by
society
to mean different things for different
people success for black male
is different than success for a white
male success for a woman is different
than success for a man
success for a white woman is different
than success for a a black woman
i personally try to define success
myself and i
more heavily rely on being significant
in this life than being successful
because if you let someone else define
success for you
then you will chase someone else's
ambitions instead of chasing your own
moving on to instagram
seriously it's actually me will you ever
have colin kaepernick on
i would love to have a conversation with
colin kaepernick absolutely
i try to make my conversations organic
the first person i had a conversation
with matthew mcconaughey
i got a call on a saturday morning 8 35
a.m i'm sitting downstairs eating some
french toast i love my french toast i
love my quiet time
my phone rings no caller id number i
pick it up because when a no caller id
number calls you you have to pick it up
if nothing else
out of curiosity i pick it up all i hear
is ocho
mcconaughey here mcconaughey like
matthew mcconaughey
he proceeds to tell me like hey he wants
to have a conversation so i like to have
my conversations organically if i hear
from colin kaepernick
i would jump at the opportunity to have
a genuine conversation and more than
anything
continue to give him a platform to share
his heart share his thoughts
time will tell and we will see does he
know what questions you're going to ask
ah in reference to my conversation with
commissioner goodell
uh roger goodell does not know what
questions i'm going to ask no guest that
comes on my show
knows what questions i'm going to ask
because i don't want to lose the organic
nature of the
conversations a conversation isn't truly
a conversation
if you script the conversation then it
just becomes a scripted q a
and so roger goodell nor any of my other
guests know what questions i'm going to
ask
they know the overarching topic matter
they know the subject matter
but they don't know exactly what's
coming because i want to keep it organic
for you the viewer i like the broach you
wear
can you share anything about it where
could i purchase it thank you
ah sarah loves great question so many
guys were wearing lapel pins you know
the cute little flowers i realize
i don't want to be like everybody else
emmanuel lacho can't be like everybody
else
so i went to the store and i went to the
brooch section i had no idea what a
broach is i thought only women wear
brooches but apparently men wear
brooches too
i found the most masculine brooches i
could find this brooch being
a leaf belief isn't necessarily
masculine but i was like whatever i
think
i got it from like macy's but you can
get a broke really from wherever
so sarah loves three step up your broach
game
more twitter hey brother love your
conversation series
following it daily can we get a serious
voter registration push
in there great great great great
question
i don't really create the conversations
myself i poll people i ask people like
you michael
what do you want me to talk about so
appreciate you saying that and putting
that in the deck
voting is important voting has always
been important black people specifically
we
fought we marched we protested we
boycotted
for the right to vote so my brothers my
sisters make sure you go out there and
vote that is my many push
as i can integrate it into the series
michael i will do my best going forward
a lot of things on the docket a huge
year ahead of us
as it pertains to the state of our
nation so make sure you go out there and
vote
adam manuel acho any plans for public
office
no absolutely not no there are no plans
for public office
as soon as you get into politics people
may
hate you or disdain you for no other
reason then you're affiliated with a
certain political group
i don't want that my goal is to be a
bridge for love reconciliation
hope joy coming together so no plans for
public office
just plans for more fire twitter and
instagram content
hey adam emanuel emmanuel i support what
you're doing
and was deeply disturbed by the george
floyd video
but if kaepernick's issue wasn't with
the flag why did he oppose a nike flag
shoe
help us understand the inconsistencies
cap is the wrong
person to lead this movement um john
what's crazy is i'm not gonna sit here
and completely disagree with some of the
things you said
cap didn't necessarily choose to lead
this
movement remember this movement chose
cap after cat put his name in the hat
i didn't necessarily choose to be a
catalyst for this movement
i just made a video out of the
brokenness and despair in my heart
that resonated with the world and at
that point in time i realized john
i have to step up and be a leader and i
would argue to a degree the same thing
happened with cap
if you would ask colin kaepernick in
2016 hey man you do realize in four
years we're still going to be talking
about you
this is going to become incredibly
divisive you're going to do
x y or z i think you'd be like huh i'm
just trying to throw some touchdown
passes
and help save lives against police
brutality
so i do think that cap has made some
missteps
i don't think that he's the wrong person
to lead this movement and i also
wouldn't say that colin kaepernick is
leading this movement
colin kaepernick is one of several
people who have voiced an
issue with systemic racism police
brutality systemic injustice
people have made him the leader but
we're all
at least anybody that's running this
race we should be running it together
this is a group
fight against evil this is a collective
battle
colin kaepernick he made some missteps
shouldn't have worn pig socks
that was a misstep he wore some t-shirts
he probably shouldn't have done
misstep but don't let one man's
errors few minor missteps detract from
the major
issue because the issue at hand we
should all be able to agree on
next up youtube
i've got a big question as an extension
to mcconaughey's question about
what is my responsibility what is your
responsibility
and that's where do black people's
responsibilities
end i've seen read and heard white
people having conversations with their
black friends
or family talking about racism and white
people's role in anti-racism
and wonder how that might be affecting a
regular black person just trying to live
their life
who might not have all the answers to
how to fight or end racism
and might not want to have to take on
the role of a racism tutor to every
white person they meet
the burden of racism takes on enough of
a heavy role in every black person's
life
at what point can they say this just
isn't their responsibility
when i talk about the responsibility i
view it like this
if i can be real if i can be
uncomfortable white people no longer
need black people for the advancement of
society they kind of got
all that juice out the squeeze so to
speak during slavery right now white
people still need black people for
entertainment
for music athletics so if white
people are now ready willing finally
to have these conversations to open up
for dialogue then i'm choosing to have
that dialogue
it's not a black person's responsibility
um but i said this in my very first
episode i said my white brothers and
sisters consider this a safe space
and sentences later i said if the white
person is your problem
only the white person can be your
solution and so
my goal uh is to continue to help
people help people help them help us
that's the figure of speech we use in
sports
that's the figure of speech i use for
this so it's not a black person's
responsibility my black brothers and
sisters
it's not your responsibility but i'm
choosing
to do something because i personally
think that it'll work
next question is the book gonna
encompass
only black and white or will it be
multicultural in the book uncomfortable
conversations with a black man
it is not just a transcription of
previous episodes it's not just a
regurgitation of previous episodes i
dive
deeper into layers of conversations that
i just don't have time to talk about
with my vocal cords
it is multicultural in the sense that
more than it is just a race issue
it's a culture issue i'm first
generation american my parents born and
raised in nigeria
i go back to nigeria each and every year
each and every summer for a medical
mission trip so
while i am black by skin color i am
cultured in a nigerian fashion
however i went to an affluent white
private school from 5th grade to 12th
grade
so i fully understand white culture
because i was immersed in that
then i played football in the university
of texas and in the national football
league and i was fully immersed in black
culture so i understand that
my life is multicultural uncomfortable
conversations with the black man the
book
it's multicultural as well so what's
happening with the youtube series
will we get more or is this over i
learned some valuable
lessons from this series one thank you
steve steve steve
two the series isn't over these
conversations i don't know if and when
they do stop but they're not stopping
from me anytime soon i want to continue
to dive
into and touch on so many other
questions along
other topics a lot of things are
uncomfortable race
religion sex sexual orientation so many
conversations are uncomfortable in our
society my goals stand as a bridge and a
gap
for all these conversations because the
conversations the series
my show is organic it's not like your
standard tv show that's going to come on
every week 7 p.m and you're all going to
be ready for it
i let the conversations come to me and
when there is content
and a conversation that is worthy of
your
time you the viewers time that is when i
tried to deliver it
so great question steve steve steve
steve that's
it thanks for hanging with me emmanuel
acho i'm signing off the internet now